[Musik]
diplomatenschutz
Rettung von Schweizerinnen und
Schweizern aus Kriegsgebieten
Räumung exponierter Gebäude
Geiselbefreiung
[Musik]
Repatriierung
Informationsbeschaffung und Infiltration
wo sonst niemand Zugang hat
all dies beherrschen die Angehörigen
einer sehr speziellen Einheit der
Schweizer Armee
[Musik]
auf dem Boden
in der Luft und auf dem Meer bereiten
Sie sich auf spontaneinsätze irgendwo
auf der Welt vor
[Musik]
ganz diskret waren sie in jüngster Zeit
an hochriskanten Missionen beteiligt
so zum Beispiel im August 2021 im Rahmen
der Evakuation Hunderter von Menschen
aus Kabul als die afghanische Hauptstadt
in die Hände der Taliban fehlen
[Musik]
oder Ende Februar 2022 in Kiew zur
Unterstützung des Schweizer Botschafters
in der Ukraine im Zuge der russischen
Invasion
die Zivilkleidung umgeben sie den
Botschafter vor der Abfahrt des Konvois
mit Schweizer Diplomaten und
Staatsangehörigen aus
[Musik]
wer sind diese geheimnisvollen Akteure
auf fremdem Staatsgebiet
es sind Profis
Angehörige einer Schweizer Elitetruppe
schnell unauffällig entschlossen
ein Stoßtrupp im Dienst der Schweizer
Armee
Codename AAD 10 kurz für Armee
aufklärungs-
zwei Jahre lang haben wir sie begleitet
wir versuchen den Schleier über ihre
Existenz zu lüften
[Musik]
unsere Geschichte beginnt im Schlafsaal
einer Kaserne am Fuße des Monte general
weit von Kabul oder Kiew entfernt
hier schlafen die Teilnehmer der
erbarmungslosen Selektion des ard-10 der
erste morgen einer wochenlangen
Bewährungsprobe
der Wecker klingelt mitten in der Nacht
wer in 15 Minuten nicht in Uniform und
mit dem notfallgepäck bereitsteht hat
schon versagt bevor es richtig losgeht
in der ersten Woche da kommt jeder seine
Chance zum Teil ist es ein Test zum Teil
gibt es eine Grundausbildung weil wir
Leute mit sehr unterschiedlichen
Werdegang haben wir geben jedem eine
Chance sich zu bewähren
in der dreiwöchigen Selektion testen und
bewerten wir Ihre körperliche und
geistige Leistungsfähigkeit wir wollen
herausfinden ob wir sie als künftige
Angehörige des ard-10 für geeignet
halten ich persönlich wünsche Ihnen
alles Gute und viel Erfolg in diesen
drei Wochen
jedes Jahr bewerben sich etwa 400
Kandidaten für diese Lektion des AAC 10
nach einer ersten Reihe medizinische und
psychologischer Tests kommen 15 in die
engere Wahl diese 15 Aspiranten
begleiten wir durch ihre dreiwöchigen
Abschlussprüfungen
höchstens drei von ihnen schaffen es bis
zum Schluss und gehören dann zu Elite
der Schweizer Armee
drei der Aspiranten tragen die Decknamen
dann Nummer zwei Leon Nummer 9 und Scott
Nummer 4 zu ihrem Schutz will die Armee
wieder Alter noch Identität oder
Herkunft der Kandidaten preisgeben
[Musik]
wenn man nicht weiß was auf einen
zukommt die Ausbildung ist
bekanntermaßen sehr hart man wird ans
Limit geführt aber wenn die Instruktoren
es geschafft haben wieso nicht auch wir
also packen wir es an Schritt für
Schritt
den Kandidaten ist das
Ausbildungsprogramm nicht bekannt der
Kommandant des ard-10 der die gesamte
Selektion begleitet hat ganz spezifische
Vorstellungen er braucht Leute die
körperlich und geistig einer
dreiwöchigen Bewährungsprobe gewachsen
sind ohne zu wissen was von ihnen genau
erwartet wird
wir brauchen Leute mit Selbstdisziplin
statt sie anzuschreien und ihnen dauernd
Feedback zu geben lassen wir die
Kandidaten im eigenen Saft schmoren und
schauen wie sie auf verschiedene
Situationen reagieren
es ist schwierig die eigenen Kräfte zu
dosieren weil wir das Programm nicht
kennen und nicht wissen was als nächstes
auf uns wartet wir müssen ja stets alles
geben aber wenn man alles gibt und keine
Reserven mehr hat dann könnte es
schwierig werden man muss den goldenen
Mittelweg finden
ich hoffe in die engere Wahl zu kommen
dann wird man sehen ob man der Sache
gewachsen ist und die drei Wochen
übersteht ob sie uns wollen oder nicht
es ist von so vielen Faktoren abhängig
durch eine Reihe von Einzel- und
Gruppenübungen werden die Kandidaten
schnell an ihrer Grenzen geführt
schon nach zwei Tagen wirft ein erster
Aspirant das Handtuch
in Deklaration
und kann sich kein zweites Mal um unsere
Selektion bewerben
für ihn aber es ist klar dass die schon
in einer Stunde kommen könnten und bei
mir dann auch Schluss wäre man macht
besser keine Fehler sonst wird man
schnell in die Mangel genommen
endlose Märsche ziellose
Orientierungsläufe in schwierigem
Gelände immer wieder schlaflose Nächte
[Musik]
diese Lektion soll alle Aspekte der
Persönlichkeit eines Kandidaten ans
Licht bringen Stärken wie Schwächen
[Musik]
und auf die Zähne beißen einen Tag lang
geht das aber wenn es eine Woche lang
regnet und du blasen und so hast wird es
körperlich und geistig schwierig
man muss auch improvisieren können das
ist das anspruchsvollste auf Märchen zu
improvisieren und die Zeit und das Essen
richtig einzuteilen
wer durchhalten will muss mit Einsamkeit
und Leiden umgehen können dann versucht
es mit einfachen Mitteln
die kleinen Freuden des Lebens wie
Zähneputzen oder eine essensreserve
diese kleinen Freuden helfen
durchzuhalten und sei es auch nur das
Wechseln der Unterhose oder der Socken
schon das kann zum Glücksgefühl werden
diese Lektion wird auch durch einen
Psychologen überwacht Jerome Andras er
ist auf das Erkennen von Risikoprofilen
spezialisiert und arbeitet mit den
Rekruten in der Funktion eines
persönlichkeitsprofilers
classic das Erkennen von Risiken ist die
Hauptaufgabe der forensischen
Psychologie
bei der Rekrutierung müssen wir erkennen
welche Personen ein Risiko für das
aad-10 Darstellen
es geht um Risiken im Einsatz aber auch
Risiken für die Personen selbst weil sie
vielleicht kognitiv oder von der
Persönlichkeit her nicht die nötigen
Voraussetzungen erfüllen um erfolgreich
tätig zu sein
die Kandidaten verlieren zunehmend ihr
Zeitgefühl
mit einer Reihe von Märchen tagsüber und
nachts wird ihre Widerstandsfähigkeit
gegenüber dem Aufgeben auf die Probe
gestellt
und aufgegeben wird regelmäßig
hat heute auch jemand aufgehört
okay ja das wusste ich noch nicht
keine Ahnung wer aber
ist ja
was soll ich sagen ist schade wenn es
gute Kameraden sind
Scott Nummer vier findet aufgeben in
einem Selektionsverfahren absolut normal
en Wettstreit letztlich will jeder
besser sein als die anderen was eine nur
weiterbringen kann und in einer Gruppe
kann man mehr leisten
die dritte Woche ist angebrochen in
dieser Nacht steht eine der härtesten
Prüfungen an ein Orientierungsmarsch in
schwierigem Gelände und über lange
Distanz in den Bergen des Jura
ein ausscheidungs-wettkampf in dem die
Zeit entscheidet und die Aspiranten nach
mehr als 10 Tagen ohne genügend Schlaf
schon sehr gezeichnet sind
der Kommandant der Truppe schaut nur zu
er mischt sich in keiner Weise ein der
Aspirant ist komplett auf sich allein
gestellt Erfolg oder Misserfolg hängt
ausschließlich von seinen Entscheidungen
ab
wir nehmen uns die Zeit genau zu
analysieren wie sie die Prüfungen
bewältigen
[Musik]
erinnerungen werden wach man sieht ja
vor allem wie sie leiden es gibt Phasen
die sind ganz schön schwierig also weckt
das schon Erinnerungen
diese Übung zeigt wie es mit dem Willen
und dem Durchhaltevermögen steht wenn
die Kandidaten erschöpft und auf sich
allein gestellt sind
brutal echt schwierig ein ganz anderer
Rhythmus als letzte Woche
von gestern 16 Uhr bis heute früh um
vier das sind doch einige Kilometer
es geht auch um die Überlebensfähigkeit
ohne jede Unterstützung wann und unter
welchen Bedingungen gibt jemand auf oder
hält eben durch
am besten das Ziel erreiche man essen
wann Pause machen wie viel zu trinken
das ist so ziemlich die primär Sachen
die die überlegt habe
dann die Nummer zwei will trotz
Problemen weiter daran glauben
ich habe richtige Durchhänger gehabt den
Weg nicht mehr gefunden und mich verirrt
und klar manchmal willst du einfach
alles hinschmeißen aber dann kommt
wieder der Traum hoch den du hast ich
will mein Ziel erreichen also einfach
weiter auf die Zähne beißen
Nummer 9 Leon der ewige Optimist hat
seinen Humor nicht verloren
zu Beginn wollte ich einfach nur Spaß
daran haben aber dann hat mich der Spaß
im Stich gelassen jetzt versuche ich
mich durch ein Stück Salami oder Käse zu
motivieren
wir sind auf der Suche nach Leuten die
in der Lage sind in einer sehr akuten
Stresssituation teamfähig zu bleiben
davon brauchen wir Menschen die
persönlich mit sich im Reinen also zum
Beispiel nicht zu impulsiv sind eine
gewisse Aggressivität ja aber nicht zu
viel warum der Christian
zudem Interesse für die anderen eine
gewisse Empathie unsere Leute dürfen
nicht gleichgültig sein müssen aber in
brenzligen Situationen einen kühlen Kopf
bewahren können
Scott Nummer vier hat sich zwei Jahre
lang Minute auf diese Lektion
vorbereitet er wollte als Kind schon
einer Sondertruppe angehören
mein Traum ist immer dabei jetzt an
diesem Freitagmorgen denke ich
allerdings eher ans Schlafen als an den
Traum meine Schulter schmerzt und ich
muss so schnell wie möglich was dagegen
tun sonst geht es kaum weiter
egal wie weit Gottes in den drei Wochen
gebracht hat seine Schulterverletzung
scheint ernsthaft zu sein Okay
aufgrund der Schulterverletzung die wir
festgestellt haben nehmen wir sie raus
und lassen Sie von einem Spezialisten
untersuchen
können oder ein militärischer Fall
daraus wird
sehr wenig Hoffnung dass sie im
aktuellen Zustand heute Nachmittag schon
wieder weitermachen können alles klar
für Sie
[Musik]
ein paar Stunden später fällt die
Entscheidung Scott wird aus
medizinischen Gründen aus der Selektion
genommen
es ist für mich sehr ärgerlich zumal ich
den Marsch sehr motiviert angetreten
hatte
ich war guten Mutes und alles lief gut
einmal dieses körperliche Missgeschick
sehr traurig
abgesehen von den Prüfungen die wir
filmen dürfen werden die drei Wochen
über auch zahlreiche geheime Tests
durchgeführt
man stelle sich realitätsnahe
Situationen vor wie sie in
Konfliktgebieten auftreten können
harte Fördermethoden Verlust von
Orientierungspunkten für die Sinne
Isolationshaft
gute Nachrichten für dein Leon und
Werner
sie gehören zu den selektionierten
[Musik]
nun wartet ein einjähriger Grundkurs mit
sechs monatiger Probezeit auf Sie
[Musik]
schaffen Sie den Kurs so winkt ein
Vertrag auf unbestimmte Zeit und Sie
werden Schritt für Schritt ins
okay neues auftragen
[Musik]
de Operationen weiß genau was es braucht
um sich als recruit in der Elite der
Armee zu bewähren
eines vorweg Sondertruppen in der
Schweiz haben nichts mit dem zu tun was
man im Kino sieht
dele
im Selektionsprozess werden die
Kandidaten von Anfang an mit der
Realität in der Schweiz und bei
Einsätzen vertraut gemacht
jeder Soldat der von Einsätzen träumt
bevor er der Truppe überhaupt angehört
verliert von Beginn an seine Illusionen
der Soldat den wir suchen ist ein
autonomer Mensch der die Absicht seines
Vorgesetzten verstehen und entsprechend
entscheiden kann ohne dass man im
systematisch sagen muss was konkret zu
tun ist und wie ihr vorgehen soll
zur Rekrutierung gehört auch das
Erkennen von Leuten mit den nötigen
eigenmotivationen die jahrelang auf
Abruf und dennoch damit zufrieden sein
können dass man sich auf etwas sehr
bedeutendes vorbereitet aber eventuell
nie zum Einsatz kommt
wir brauchen keine Hitzköpfe die nur auf
eine Mission aus sind
das AAD 10 wurde 2004 gegründet sein
Budget ist nach wie vor militärisches
Geheimnis
2007 nahm es seinen Dienst auf seit hier
ist die Rede von 16 Millionen Franken
kein Dementi seitens der Armee
der Personalbestand des aad-10 liegt
aktuell bei knapp 100 Frauen gibt es im
ARD momentan keine auch wenn ihnen der
Zugang offen steht
[Musik]
die übliche Arbeitszeit dieser Truppe
besteht grob gesagt zu je einem Drittel
aus einsetzen und aus Schulung
das letzte Drittel ist schlicht und
einfach der Erholung gewidmet
das ist eine ausgewogene Mischung mit
der man doch zufrieden sein kann sie
ermöglicht uns eine erhöhte Bereitschaft
für alle möglichen Einsätze die in der
Vereinbarung mit der Politik vorgesehen
sind
die meisten Einsätze des ard-10 finden
im Ausland statt wo die Interessen der
Schweiz zu verteidigen sind
Einsätze im Inland sind aber nicht
ausgeschlossen so war im Juni 2021 ein
aad Kontingent im Rahmen des
Gipfeltreffens zwischen beiden und Putin
in Genf auszumachen aktuell Politik
würde sie aktuell kann die Politik auf
Antrag kantonaler Behörden beschließen
Schweizer Sondertruppen im Inland
einzusetzen so etwas ist also durchaus
möglich
die Präsident
zwischen beiden und putin war es zum
Beispiel so dass die Genfer Polizei über
die lokalen Behörden einen Antrag an die
Bundesbehörden stellte und um bestimmte
Sicherheitsdienste auf dem Seebad
wir sind Generalisten wir bereiten uns
auf alles Mögliche vor aber
Personenschutz gehört natürlich zu
unseren Kernkompetenzen ich meine
natürlich Personenschutz im Ausland der
in der Schweiz kaum realistisch geübt
werden kann
wir wurden eingeladen verschiedene
Diplomaten und personenschutzübungen der
Truppe zu filmen eine Premiere
wir sind in Bern in dieser Übung soll
der Schutz Schweizer Diplomaten im
Ausland möglichst realitätsgetreu
nachgestellt werden
unsere Leute sollen in jeder möglichen
Situation in einer Krisenregion das
Richtige tun und bedrohungsgerecht
reagieren können
die Gruppe Alpha plant die Komponenten
der Operation wie Routen Art des
Schutzes Fahrzeuge Bewaffnung oder
Fluchtwege bis ins Kleinste
detail-risiko gerecht und
realitätsgeträumt
[Musik]
Beatrice Scheer Protokoll Chefin und
Beamtin im eidgenössischen Departement
für auswärtige Angelegenheiten steht in
ständigem Kontakt mit Diplomaten und
Staatschefs
in dieser Übung fingiert Sie die zu
schützende Person
[Musik]
mein Eindruck ist dass ich es mit
hochmotivierten äußerst erfahrenen und
sehr professionellen Leuten zu tun habe
die sich sehr seriös vorbereiten
sie sind bereit ihr Leben aufs Spiel zu
setzen und das ist nicht
selbstverständlich
sie bereiten sich nicht auf einen
Sonntagsspaziergang vor sondern auf
Situationen in denen sie und die zu
schützenden Personen einer Gefahr
ausgesetzt sind ich habe großen Respekt
dass sie dafür ihr Leben riskieren
für die Schweizer protokollchefin ist
diese Truppe mit lebenswichtigem
Know-how ausgestattet dass sich nicht
spontan herbeizaubern lässt wenn du ja
lanessa deswegen der ganze Aufwand diese
Leute die uns schützen müssen am Tag X
das Richtige tun können
sie nicht einfach auf die Schnelle
darauf vorbereiten wenn etwas geschieht
es ist deshalb absolut gerechtfertigt
eine Sondertruppe zu haben die letztlich
unserer Sicherheit dient
[Musik]
als Beispiel ein konkreter Einsatz
Schweizer Botschaft in Kiew Mitte
Februar 2022 wenige Tage vor dem
Einmarsch Russlands
die Schweiz befürchtet das Schlimmste
das AAD 10 ist mit von der Partie
Botschafter Claude wild zu den Tagen
unmittelbar vor dem Krieg
die Verstärkung durch das AAD 10
bedeutete noch nicht zwingend dass eine
Evakuation bevorstand aber sie war
möglich
Verstärkung hieß erstmal krisenmodus
damals wollten wir noch so lange wie
möglich bleiben und abwarten ob Kiew
unter Beschuss genommen wurde
angesichts der Bewaffnung der
vorrückenden Truppen wurde uns klar dass
wir gehen mussten
okay Chef Kollege liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen die Lage ist schwierig
ich wünsche allen viel Glück auf einer
schwierigen Reise auf bald wir werden
sehen wie bald vielen Dank auch an die
Leute die uns verstärken unsere
Sondertruppe
[Musik]
humanitärenkräfte den Ort verließen
Grundsatzfrage welchen Status haben
Schweizer Sondertruppen auf
ausländischem Boden
sind sie Top-Agenten im Dienst der
Diplomaten
oder der Neutralität verpflichtete
Militärs
sie gelten vor Ort als
Botschaftspersonal mit der Aufgabe die
Sicherheit der für die politische Arbeit
der Schweiz zuständigen
Botschaftsangehörigen zu gewährleisten
das aad-10 ist offenbar weit mehr als
ein normaler Sicherheitsdienst
[Musik]
diese Leute sind für den Einsatz gemacht
sie sind keine normalen Befehlsempfänger
sie werden dazu ausgebildet Lösungen zu
finden
genau das habe ich als Missionschef
enorm geschätzt in kürzester Zeit bieten
sie verschiedene Lösungen an
problemansprach hatte ich innerhalb
einer halben Stunde zwei oder drei
Lösungsmöglichkeiten
das aller schwierigste war dass die Lage
ständig neu beurteilt werden musste um
entscheiden zu können ob wir gehen und
auf welchem Weg so viel
müssen wir gehen wenn ja wann allein
oder mit anderen Botschaften andere
planten einen gemeinsamen Konvoi wir
entschieden uns für den Alleingang im
kleinen Konvoi über Landstraßen was ich
als richtige Entscheidung herausstellte
zum Glück lief alles gut bei diesem
Abzug aus Kiew es gab wieder
Zwischenfälle noch Beschuss
was wäre geschehen wäre man mit Truppen
zusammengestoßen oder in einen
Hinterhalt geraten
was wäre wenn Schweizer Soldaten bei
einer Konfrontation mit russischen
Truppen töten oder getötet werden
eine solche absolut denkbare Katastrophe
könnte der Schweizer Neutralität Schaden
zufügen
große Bedenken hat Thomas süssli Chef
der Schweizer Armee jedoch nicht im
Gegenteil er meint die Schweizer
Öffentlichkeit begegnet seinen
Elitetruppen im Ausland mit Wohlwollen
was man gut spürt ist auch in der
Bevölkerung dass es ein Wechsel gegen
hat in der Wahrnehmung der Sicherheit
dass man hat mit wahrgenommen dass
Kriege auch in Europa möglich sind aber
auch Leute in den Bevölkerung ja die
Wahrnehmung hat geändert und die kann
man sich bewusst geworden dass die Armee
als Gesamtsystem dass die einen
wichtigen Beitrag für die Sicherheit von
uns allen leistet und da ist natürlich
das die Spezialkräfte sind hier
eingeschlossen bei dieser Beurteilung
in der Politik wird die Zweckmäßigkeit
des ard-10 kaum angezweifelt nicht
einmal von links
dafür stehen heikle Fragen im Raum wer
trägt die Verantwortung für den Einsatz
Schweizer Truppen im Ausland wer muss
darüber informiert werden wann kann
informiert werden ohne die Operation zu
gefährden
Fabian Molina von der SP ärgert sich
darüber dass das Parlament erst nach
Entsendung des aad-10 in die Ukraine und
nach Afghanistan informiert wurde das
Parlament wurde nicht über den Einsatz
der ADC in der Ukraine informiert
nachträglich haben wir davon erfahren
aber es fand keine Diskussion darüber
statt die Bundesverfassung sieht vor
dass die Außenpolitik eine gemeinsame
Aufgabe von Parlament und Bundesrat ist
und auf diesem Recht des Parlaments
mitzuwirken gilt es zu bestehen
die außenpolitische Kommission des
Nationalrates soll das demokratische
Vorgehen des Bundesrates in der
Außenpolitik gewährleisten
vom Einsatz Schweizer Soldaten in
Afghanistan hat sie aus der Presse
erfahren
die Kommission hat beim Bundesrat eine
offizielle Protestnote eingereicht
ich bin ehrlich gesagt etwas genervt
über die Haltung des Bundesrates der
sich in verschiedenen Bereichen über die
Bundesverfassung und das
parlamentsgesetz hinweggesetzt im
Bereich der Außenpolitik der die
Mitwirkung des Parlaments beschneidet im
Falle der Ukraine hat es sich auch um
eine
evakuierungsmission gehandelt es ist
glücklicherweise gut gegangen es war ein
sehr professioneller Einsatz
gleichzeitig gab es natürlich ein Risiko
das wenn es zu Zusammenstößen gekommen
wäre zwischen russischen Truppen und der
ad-10 dass die Schweiz schon sehr früh
in diesen Konflikt hineingezogen worden
wäre
stirbt ein Soldat oder Westfalen Schüsse
zwischen zwei
Armenien und die Schweiz ist
Konfliktpartei und das hat dann sehr
schnell einen Flächenbrand zur Folge
wir wollten die für die Armee zuständige
Bundesrätin Viola Amherd dazu befragen
sie hat abgelehnt und es ihrem Armeechef
überlassen sich zu der Kritik zu äußern
die Armee handelt immer unter der
Politik unter dem primatenpolitik es ist
ein politischer Entscheid auch die
Informationshoheit liegt dann bei der
Politik und wenn es einen Antrag gibt er
auf dem regulären Weg zu uns kommt dann
beantworten wir diesen und informieren
auch für den Armeechef steht die
Entscheidungskette in Bezug auf das
ard-10 außer Frage der Bundesrat hat
Vorrang
und es ist dann an der politischen Stufe
zu entscheiden ob das Parlament auch
informiert werden muss
fast zwei Jahre warteten wir darauf dass
ard-10 zu einem Auslandeinsatz begleiten
zu dürfen letztlich wurde aus
Geheimhaltungsgründen nichts daraus
Diskretion sei ausschlaggebend für den
Erfolg einer Operation hieß es wir
müssten uns damit begnügen Übungen
mitzuverfolgen
keine Medien keine Politikerinnen und
Politiker die Frage ist also nicht mehr
was die Elite Soldaten genau tun sondern
wer die politische Kontrolle über die
Truppe ausübt ich glaube die
Notwendigkeit der ard-10 als
Rückversicherung für die Schweiz für den
äußersten Notfall stellt praktisch
niemand mehr in Frage aber wie wir aus
dem Privatleben wissen auch
Versicherungen müssen kontrolliert
werden und das aad-10 hat es seit dem
Beginn seiner konkreten Einsätze im Jahr
2007 weit gebracht damals kam die
Sondertruppe unter Geburtswehen Zustande
auch wenn heute nur noch die Frage der
politischen Aufsicht umstritten ist
zu Beginn schlug dem ard-10 eine Welle
der Kritik entgegen und zwar von der
pazifistischen linken genauso wie von
der konservativen rechten Christoph
Blochers SVP Saga die Neutralität
gefährdet
beinahe zum Debakel für das ard-10 wird
vor allem die Affäre Max Göldi und
Rashid haben Dani die beiden Schweizer
werden
2008/2009 in Libyen durch den
unberechenbaren oberstaddafi als Geiseln
festgehalten
fast zwei Jahre lang sind die Schweiz
und Libyen miteinander im Klitsch
[Musik]
eleinheit
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
im Auftrag des Eder und der Mischling
Kamera soll das noch junge aad-10 einen
Geheimplan zur Befreiung der Geiseln in
Libyen aushecken
gestützt auf das Öffentlichkeitsgesetz
haben wir uns die starke
schwärzenunterlagen zu dieser Mission
der Schweizer Armee beschafft sie
bestätigen die damals in der Presse
erschienenen Informationen
das AAD 10 entwickelte drei absolute
James Bond würdige fluchtszenarien
Szenario 1 durch die Wüste über Algerien
Szenario 2 durch den Niger mit Hilfe der
Touareg
das dritte und abenteuerlichste Szenario
sah vor dass die beiden Geiseln beim
Schwimmen im Meer vor Tripolis unter den
Augen ihrer Wächter vortäuschen sollten
zu ertrinken
vorschmänner des aad-10 sollten mit
Sauerstoffflaschen auf die beiden Männer
warten und sie in einem U-Boot eines
befreundeten Staates Ausschleusen
keines dieser Szenarien kommt über das
Planungsstadium hinaus aber sie finden
den Weg in die Presse
der Bundesrat kommt von allen Seiten
unter Beschuss die Verfassung und die
Neutralität der Schweiz sein in Gefahr
libyen hat exemplarisch gezeigt dass der
Bundesrat außenpolitisch auch Fehler
machen kann wenn er in großer
Intransparenz und am Parlament vorbei
handelt wir hatten damals zwei Geißen
die wahrscheinlich länger
gefangen gehalten wurden als nötig weil
der Bundesrat grobe Fehler gemacht hat
die Libyen-Affäre anders sie habe dem
ard-10 dazu verholfen aus seinem
Dornröschenschlaf zu erwachen
es war eine aufschlussreiche Operation
sie war kompliziert zog sich über
mehrere Jahre hin und gab letztlich auch
dem Departement für auswärtige
Angelegenheiten die Möglichkeit die
Fähigkeiten unserer Leute zu erkennen
und vor allem sie schätzen zu lernen
dass debatement für auswärtige
Angelegenheiten ist heute einer der
wichtigsten Auftraggeber des aadc
10 Jahre nach der Libyen-Affäre hat sich
alles eingespielt das ard-10 kann heute
im Auftrag des EDA Schweizer Geiseln aus
feindlichen Gebieten befreien was auch
seinem Ausbildungszweck entspricht
[Musik]
als Kabul fiel war ein AD10 Kommando in
Rekordzeit vor Ort
die Operation unterliegt nach wie vor
der militärgeheimnis aber der Kommando
Leiter darf uns ausnahmsweise ein paar
Details verraten
früher Nachmittag ist 13 August ein
erstes Telefon erhalten in welchem ich
informiert wurde dass sein Einsatz zu
Unterstützung des ETA im Bereich
Evakuation Kabul Afghanistan kommen
könnte ich habe daraufhin unmittelbar
einige unserer Leute in eine erhöhte
Bereitschaft gesetzt wir haben ein
erstes Team zusammengestellt das für
einen möglichen Einsatz damals war noch
unklar um was es konkret geht
bereitstehen würde
stellvertretender Chef des
krisenmanagementzentrums des EDA spricht
über die Operation
unser Auftrag war klar in erster Linie
das Personal unserer Vertretung und
seine Angehörigen repatriieren danach
weitere Personen gemäß einer Liste
Direktion für die Durchführung einer
Operation im Rahmen einer Krise im
Ausland sind das EDA und sein
krisenmanagementzentrum zuständig
wir treffen auch im Verlauf der
Operation die nötigen Entscheidungen
gemäß der Strategie das ard-10 ist in
diesem Sinne ein Dienstleister des EDA
Pole DFV sondern am 16 August wurde die
Aktion den ausgelöst und wird flogen am
Abend kurz nach 10 Uhr mit einer
Maschine des lufttransportes
nach Taschkent Usbekistan und haben dort
einerseits die Kontaktaufnahme mit dem
deutschen
fallschirmjägerargiment vorgenommen in
welches für integriert wurden
während die Schweizer Sondertruppen in
der Ausbildung über die ganze Palette
von fortbeweg vermitteln verfügen müssen
sie sich im Einsatz oft mit den
militärischen Mitteln befreundeter
Truppen vor Ort begnügen
zur Repatriierung von Schweizern aus dem
Chaos am Flughafen Kabul musste sich das
ard-10 den Transportmöglichkeiten der
deutschen anschließen
das Kommando des ard-10 in Kabul besteht
aus sechs Angehörigen der Sondertruppen
und zwei zivilen Sicherheitsberater des
Eder
diese kleine Gruppe ist zwar mobil und
flexibel aber der Erfolg ihrer Operation
hängt von der Infrastruktur eines großen
Nachbarlandes ab
um petite präsentiert konnten mit einem
kleinen Kontingent auskommen weil
Deutschland als bevorzugter Partner
bereits mit den nötigen Infrastruktur
und Logistik vor Ort war Skin sagt
Pyramiden so konnten wir uns auf die
Menschen konzentrieren und letztlich
eine sehr positive Bilanz ziehen wir
haben in dieser Operation insgesamt 385
Personen repatriiert oder evakuiert
vor Ort hat man keine Zeit oder keine
Möglichkeit um das Gesehene zu
verarbeiten dass das geschieht erst
später erst wenn man wieder zu Hause ist
es sind aber nicht nur die Bilder die
man sieht die einen später zum Teil
einholen es sind sind Geräusche Gerüche
aber insbesondere auch menschliches
Verhalten das für unsere Kultur oder
unseren Kulturraum einfach nicht
verständlich oder nicht nachvollziehbar
ist es gibt aber auch Monate nach diesem
Einsatz immer wieder Momente wo mir
gewisse Bilder einfach in den Kopf
kommen das gehört dazu Buchstabe gewisse
Sachen werden mich oder werden uns auch
unser Leben lang begleiten
erlebt es dauert natürlich eine Weile
bis die Emotionen hochkommen und alles
verarbeitet werden kann
wir machen sofort in die Briefing und
dann geben wir Ihnen die Zeit alles zu
verdauen
außerdem haben sie immer die Möglichkeit
Hilfe von einem Team von Psychologen in
Anspruch zu nehmen
wir begleiten das ard-10 zu einem
Auslandeinsatz auf einer Militärbasis
französischer Sondertruppen in
Südfrankreich
dort werden spezifische Übungen
absolviert die in der Schweiz nicht
möglich sind
im Alltag geht es darum unsere
Einsatzbereitschaft zu gewährleisten
wir uns stets Neues Know-how an damit
sind wir ebenfalls sehr beschäftigt
ein weiterer wichtiger Aspekt ist die
Wahrung unserer Kontakte zu
Sondertruppen anderer Länder oder zu den
verschiedenen Sicherheitskräften in der
Schweiz
die Angehörigen des ard-10 sind sich
bewusst dass es auf ihrem Weg keine
Feuertaufe also keine echte
Kriegserfahrung geben wird aber egal was
zählt ist die Einsatzbereitschaft
Park ist es war wir sind als Institution
im Alltag nicht präsent aber wenn es
soweit kommt dass man uns in senden muss
dann werden die Schweizerinnen und
Schweizer sicher zufrieden sein dass Sie
uns all die Jahre über auf Staatskosten
vorbereitet und ausgerüstet haben
je nach Funktion oder Dienstgrad
verdienen Angehörige des AAD 10 zwischen
70.000 und 90.000 Franken pro Jahr was
den Risiken im Alltag kaum gerecht wird
manchmal ist es schwierig weil wir
verschiedenen Risiken ausgesetzt sind
und immer etwas passieren kann
wenn ich zu Hause gefragt werde wie der
Tag gelaufen sei antworte ich sowieso
alles bestens
kürzlich ging ich 30 Meter über den
Boden mit meiner Waffe in ein sei
verwickelt an einem Helikopter und fiel
fast runter
nicht besonders schlimm aber doch mit
Stress und Emotionen verbunden die man
sich nicht anmerken lassen darf
[Musik]
für die Elite-Soldaten des ard-10 sind
Partnerschaft und Familie trotz ihres
ungewöhnlichen Alltags unter Ausschluss
der Öffentlichkeit keine Fremdwörter
sondern aus Sicht der Armee ein
wichtiges psychologisches Gegengewicht
hallo
Familie und Beruf unter einen Hut zu
bringen bedeutet für mich persönlich
beruflich alles zu tun was ich tun
möchte
und da viel zu Hause zu 100% für meine
Familie da zu sein
wegen der strikten Neutralität der
Schweiz müssen AAD 10 Angehörige damit
leben dass sie nie im Kriegseinsatz
stehen werden
ist das nicht frustrierend für derart
hochgezüchtete Soldaten
mit der Frustration
frustrierend ja und nein
natürlich verfolgen auch ihr das
internationale Geschehen
und manchmal sagt man sich das wäre doch
genau etwas für uns
man wartet ab und es kommt nichts
es ist eine ganz heikle Sache in einer
solchen Situation auf der Führungsebene
den richtigen Mittelweg zu finden
legt man Hoffnung mit dem Risiko die
Leute zu enttäuschen oder spricht man
einen möglichen Einsatz überhaupt nicht
an wodurch die Leute ihre Motivation
verlieren könnten sich für
anspruchsvolle Einsätze bereit zu halten
die es eventuell nie geben wird
dann Leon und Werner die drei
selektionierten schließen ihren
Grundkurs ab
werden Sie schon bald in einem
Konfliktgebiet im Einsatz stehen
sind Sie bereit auf sich zu nehmen was
das Leben eines Elite Soldaten im Dienst
seines Landes ausmacht
Justin
ich bin bereit mein Leben zu riskieren
[Musik]
schließlich haben wir in der Ausbildung
enorm viel dafür getan Risiken und
Gefahren zu minimieren um Unfälle und
persönliche Katastrophen zu vermeiden
dran
ich glaube es Gott wieder mit lernen vor
allem man konnte das Team lernt den
neuen
Team und dann nicht mehr eigentlich eher
schon am Anfang noch ein GK und dann kam
immer noch mehr lernen sich verbessere
und das Messel ist Niveau noch heute im
Team
ativ
und geistig vorbereitet geschwitzt und
gelitten wir haben Nächte lang nicht
richtig geschlafen und all dies im
Hinblick auf einen Einsatz im Dienst der
Schweiz unsere Mitbürgerinnen und
Mitbürger und unserer Kameraden
kurzum wir sind einsatzbereit
[Musik]
das Metier ist zweifelsohne voller
Gefahren auch wenn alle Aspiranten und
alten Hasen des ard-10 beteuern zu allem
bereit zu sein
nicht auszuschließen dass einer dieser
Soldaten mal bei einem Einsatz im
Ausland ums Leben kommt
sind Öffentlichkeit und Politik in der
Schweiz tatsächlich bereit für
militärische Opfer die verhüllt unter
der Schweizer Fahne in einem Sarg
zurückkehren
hat die Schweiz diese Erfahrung bereits
machen müssen im Rahmen von
friedensförderungsmissionen haben wir in
den letzten 70 Jahren 8 Soldaten
verloren es wäre also auch für uns
nichts neues das Kameraden in Uniform
ihr Leben verlieren
als Kommandant ist man sich dessen stets
bewusst es gibt immer ein Restrisiko
aber noch einmal es ist eine unserer
Aufgaben die Risiken zu analysieren und
die Voraussetzungen für erfolgreiche
Missionen zu schaffen aber es ist meine
Pflicht zu betonen dass es immer ein
Restrisiko gibt
bereits seit 15 Jahren führt das ard-10
im Ausland verschiedenste Einsätze unter
größter Geheimhaltung durch
bisher sind alle Soldaten wieder heil
zurückgekehrt
die kritischen Stimmen sind verstummt
die Zweckmäßigkeit dieser Schweizer
Sondertruppen wird allgemein anerkannt
auch wenn die Frage der politischen
Aufsicht ungeklärt bleibt
in einer Welt zunehmender Bedrohungen
hat das ard-10 seinen festen Platz im
Dienst des Landes gefunden
[Musik]
bleibt zur bestimmen wie das Land seine
Dienste in Zukunft nutzen will
[Musik]